okay playing double
uh plain English we'll mix it up a
little bit
how many English opening players are
there in chat with some puzzles
oh it's too late
I'm going straight into the game upon
him going for King's Indian
um
yeah as an English player you kind of
have to be prepared for King's Indian I
could have maybe delayed D4
but uh
okay I'll play a line that
I learned a while ago
actually I played this line for the
first time
in a really important OTV Tournament
game against a Wonder Liang
I think back in like 2012 or 2013
that may have been the only time I
played this on OTB
um but it was a situation I played a
wonder it was like the last round of a
nine round Norm Invitational and I
needed to win it was a crazy game but I
ended up winning
and that got me my second I am Norm
uh so the clear idea here is E5
not sure if I can
prevent E5
like there's Bishop d392
let's go for this
I could also play Queen D2 which is
maybe a little bit more flexible
and this move prevents H6 so it's nice
to have the Queen Bishop battery
and there's cases where maybe I play
Bishop E2 okay now I guess I can play
Bishop D3
I can play Knight F3 D5 is actually
what the [ __ ] planning after D5
because 95 walks into F4
and then Knight D7
we might get some four pawns attack
I push all my
my Center pawns and my CNF Pawns
uh so f497 Knight F3
there is H6 Bishop H4
imagining E6 happens at some point
let's go for it though
I'm actually thinking Bishop D3 is
slightly more accurate here
ensuring the pawns defended keeping
options open of 92 or Knight F3
thank you Andrew gifting to efos
oh IX said English opening following the
footsteps of ding Loren
is ding known for playing English
he's probably very capable of it he did
play a first round of candidates against
nepo lost to very tragic game is white
I'm wondering actually if I should just
leave my Bishop there
and let it be taken because most of my
pawns are on light squares
92 seems
solid
there's E6
and Bishop C2
the benefit of Bishop C2 is I can play
B4
hey Eric do you ever worry that your
forehead is becoming a five head
sometimes yeah especially with my
receding hairline
but maybe that's a good thing I don't
know does it make me smarter
foreign
I'm having trouble deciding
whether or not to keep my Bishop
because Bishop C2 E6 B4 looks nice
but Bishop C2 A5
and then
Knight F3 E6 Castle takes takes
some eventual 94
I'll play business key too
so keep in mind this is rapid chess so
I probably shouldn't be overthinking
things
what happened with your heart rate my
Apple watch is charging
maybe at some point I'll activate the
heart rate now F5 looks nice
or hopefully my heart rate is
still
happening despite the fact I don't have
the monitor
uh
play F5 so F5 takes takes E4 is kind of
scary looking and then G4
I'll do it this game actually reminds me
of one of Fabiano's games
from a slightly different opening
there was a game Fabiano played where he
had I think exactly the structure I
actually showed it on stream recently
uh he played some rapid tournaments in
2019 I was actually there in person I
was playing the same tournament
in the first round game he played FM
Ezra Chambers some content
and he he won a really nice game just
grabbing space with the Pawns
thank you Behavior
welcome back welcome back to everyone
I'm trying to stay somewhat focused here
like trying to
not move too slowly
down about a minute and a half
but I like the position I think we'll
actually played E6
because once G4 comes in
it kind of feels like checkers
but it's so nice having like um just a
nice grip E4 is very well defended
B4 is still an idea too I should have
probably considered B4
instead of F5
I was just too focused on uh this area
of the board
so A5 is one expected move
more of a prophylactic move
and if A5 I think I just played G4
pretty quickly
block taking time here
how do you know when to push pawns
before castling
yeah it's hard to give a general
principle I mean
yeah the king like is kind of Airy here
but the fact that
no files have opened yet
like generally if if like the center
files
begin to open or are about to open then
it's usually a good idea to try and
Castle the king quickly but given the
center of the state closed closed it's
fine to
leave the king here
um
but it does require some more
care in the position
like there's some weird Knight G3
I'm inclined just to play this move
I'm realizing Bach has an idea
of F6 of G5 and then completely closing
Zone
and then maybe later Knight F4 although
Knight F4 is not an outpost because G3
potential
so I think I can start with Knight F4
or um start with 92.
and then see what block is up to I still
have B4
another idea B4 would force this
the drawback of B4 though even though it
looks good like I expand with Tempo and
like has to retreat
uh it invites A5
and then I have to deal with like the
fact I can't really respond with A3 I
wouldn't want to play D5
so like B4 and the D7 I would need to
follow up and I'm not seeing it so let's
just play 92.
like if these moves were included and I
played Knight D2 then there'd be A5 but
uh
okay we might see G5 coming
and things could potentially close down
even more
I'm still not sure which side to Castle
or if I want to leave my king in the
center
yeah there's still this tension
I don't think it's good for black to
take though
Rook F7
is unexpected
so I think now in G4 it wins material
I could also start with B4 and blocks
basically committing I see the plan so
black is committing to Knight F4 takes
takes rookie seven and then there's
counter play I mean I could play like B4
and then Europe B1 or C5
again visually it looks really really
nice
I don't think there's that much counter
play either
let's start with B4
I like the prospect of blocking the
bishop
oh that move I forgot about
but is that really where black wants to
Knight I think just A3
wow and now we're gonna see Knight G7
oh it's a funny
configuration
I don't think Knight F4 is coming
because even if the E5 opens upon super
solid
so now it's a question how I made
progress I mean I could play C5
eventually not right now
this before
I gotta move a lot quicker too
start with H4 just creating
possibilities of G5 I mean the general
strategy when you are Pawn storming is
to try and optimize
the pieces behind the Pawns
and then look for the potential Pawn
break
so like Knight G3 Queen H2
blocks pretty restricted on the queen
side
we might see this move
be funny if we see like C5 B5
everything closes down
and this is turning into a Blitz game so
I'm gonna have to
just move a bit more quick quickly
yeah C6
um
oh yeah happy spooky season
I'm trying to Spook my opponent with my
Pawns
Bishop B3 looks enticing
because there's x-ray vision and there's
there's no potential for C5
I mean C5 G5 H5 B5 a lot of potential
Pawn breaks wow
uh I mean I can't resist I I think
that's the best move too
it's otherwise uh Knight would come to
Z5
so now I think I just Bond cloud like
King E2 and then bring the rook in
maybe I could have Castle Queen side I
mean there's still A6 potential
it's so funny that uh
the other day I forget who it was
someone emailed me of a funny picture of
one of their games
of um almost exactly the structure but
it was all interlocked like there was a
black one in A5
okay let's play this
now if it closes down completely
then
that's not good for me
and black might open the a file
but there's really no penetration points
on a file like there's Rook A3 that
I'll be able to defend
and I'm realizing the bishop should go
back to C2 because it's not doing
anything on B3
this x-ray vision is meaningless with
the pawns here
and on C2 it actually it does support
the F5 Pawn
is that the first capture of the game I
think it is okay I'll take with a pawn
opponent is trying to spoof me with
their Rooks
the benefit of having the bishop
reinforce F5 is that
I can more safely play G5
and not have to worry about losing the F
Pawn
G5 probably just comes
if takes I have F6
yeah this could crumble for lack really
quickly
uh do I play f600 takes
both moves look good
F6 takes let's just take F6 can't really
be stopped
we might see E4
but E4 just um I take and then Knight of
six is a threat
um
yeah this should be really good for
whites wow upon sagging everything now
the cookie is crumbling I think F6 I
don't even need to take the bishop
because now this this and this are all
hanging
so I'm up a rook and a bishop no
I'm up a full Rook
um and there's probably some money made
somewhere
King F7
where's my funny mate
[Music]
um
oh no my queen
someone call an ambulance
but not for me
oh what a game to start the Stream
also thank you while writes the five
gifted
what a funny finish
that was such a nice game on like on
many levels
and this game reminded me of like so
many different
previous Life Experiences
hey and I got a rose in trophy for the
pawn mate
for the pawn mate and Verona my queen
right do I get two Rosen trophies for
this game
Rosen score
for those that don't know what Rose and
trophies are if you go to rosenscore.com
[Music]
it redirects to the site
um built by Traveler
and
uh you can input your lead chest
username or you can input my lead test
username any username and then analyze
except let's just do the last six hours
hey I got two rows and trophies let's go
I wonder if there's a way to see which
game I played generated the most Frozen
trophies
it's not easy to get two in one game
let me explain a few details
wait let me first show
this is kind of coincidental someone
emailed me oh yeah it was Zippy that
emailed me the other day the subject
line of the email was funny position
triple X Lam Great Wall of Pawns and
then Zippy attached this image of this
Pawn structure
this was two days ago
and it's funny that like I could have
reached the same structure in this game
uh if my opponents like if my opponent
played A5 here
and then let's say I played this this
this this
it's a scene structure
where like this is just a draw like
objectively there's really nothing
either side could do
um now in this position actually white
could try and like Play Bishop C3 and
Sac on A5
but I think in this position A5 is just
too too well supported but of course
like I'll never allow the king side to
completely close down because I can
always control when files will open with
G5 or taking and then using that file
it's crazy that the engine gives plus
seven here
equal material too
it goes to show how much the engine
values
the space advantage
what was I also talking about oh yeah I
wanted to show
um let me see if I can find it Fabiano
caruana Azera Chambers
so anyway just uh look at the opening
and look at the pawn structure again so
I have the same structure
like very similar position this game
black played Knight C6 and Knight B8 and
Knight A6
and
yeah when I played F5
it reminded me of
this position when favion will play F5
so kudos to Fabiano for
inspiring me
and maybe many other chess players too